bonsoir mesdames et messieurs la sphère
des orgies de montréal est en train de
devenir un feuilleton politiciens qui on
est de retour à la case départ
françois cormier on se renvoie la balle
entre montréal et ottawa
et après l'ultimatum de trois jours qu'a
lancé le mercredi et hier on ne sait
toujours pas patrice si les
fonctionnaires d'environnement canada
viendront s'asseoir avec les
fonctionnaires municipaux pour discuter
de ce dossier le maire a dit aujourd'hui
répété qu'il n'avait pas besoin de
l'autorisation formelle d'environnement
canada pour pouvoir procéder aux travaux
vous vous souvenez aussi qu' elle mère
coderre avait reproché à environnement
canada d'avoir le dossier en main depuis
septembre 2014 et de ne pas avoir pris
de décision
étrangement le bureau de la ministre a
dit aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'il n'était au courant que depuis que
depuis la semaine dernière le maire a
reproché ensuite à la ministre a zappé
peut-être que vous n'étiez pas au
courant mais vos fonctionnaires l'était
et au cours de la dernière heure patrice
le bureau de madame aglukkaq a confirmé
effectivement que ces fonctionnaires
étaient au courant mais qu' elle n'avait
pas reçu une information là dessus je
vous laisse entendre le maire coderre
suivi du chef conservateur si 25 au 29
septembre avant même que je parle de
ceux qui ont du bon ben on est informé
qu'on a ces documents le cul 2014
faudrait peut-être travailler de telle
ou telle façon donc il ya des gens qui
essaient de s'en sortir
quant à paula devrait faire attention ce
qu'a dit parce que le ministère
d'environnement canada est au courant
nos ministres ont déjà exprimé leurs
frères qui assure cet égard et nous
encourageons à la vie de rencontrer
environnement qu'un degré que de
considérer d'autres possibilités pour
régler cette affaire en or pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'autres
possibilités répète la ville et françois
des déversements comme ça c'est déjà
arrivé
on le disait hier on a des précisions là
dessus oui trois des versements qui ont
eu lieu au cours des dernières années
voyons tout de suite donc à quoi ça
pouvait ressembler 2003 7 milliards de
litres c'était au printemps 2003
toujours mais à l'automne 5,6 milliards
de litres et 2005 720 millions de litres
j'attire votre attention
sur octobre et novembre 2003 qui était
ministre de l'environnement au québec à
cette époque
thomas mulcair qui a dit plus tôt cette
semaine que cette idée de déverser des
milliards de litres dans le fleuve et
est saugrenue on n'a pas de confirmation
que ce manque a un rôle à jouer dans
cette histoire mais écouter ce qu'elle
met en colère avaient à dire aujourd'hui
ils disaient qu'ils feraient jamais que
si est un premier ministre puis trouve
un sursaut venu d'envoyer des voiliers
des eaux usées dans le fleuve alors
qu'ils nous expliquent 2003 c'est arrivé
au mode de au mois d'octobre novembre
2003 qui terminait ce n'est pas qu'au
bois au québec qui a donné une
autorisation poser des questions donc
patrice pour le moment les travaux sont
toujours prévue pour le 18 octobre
plutôt que d'être 20 heures sur 24 ce
sera 24 heures sur 24 on apprécie
aujourd'hui le m commerce s'envole tout
à l'heure pour l'afrique une mission qui
était prévu il reviendra dimanche
merci françois au revoir